I'm gonna start in exactly the same way
that we do here we're gonna take a
number right we're gonna take some
polynomials that we know we can multiply
and therefore we're gonna go through the
division process okay so after thinking
that multiplication division there's
some headed years bringing these two
multigate individual to polynomials
bringing multiplication division to
pollinate that's what we're about to do
now we are going to start with my
favorite table the example I always pull
out as a first one right
my favorite quadratic which is this guy
x squared plus 5x plus 6 we're gonna
begin with me I think now you guys know
how to factorize this right you already
know what the factors are what are the
factors of X Christmas - 4 C's
I think the pair of numbers that are
going to work here we add 2 5 & welt' y
6r 2 & 3 2 & 3 so here are my factors
and this what this course was to is
saying this I can multiply these
together and get this okay therefore it
stands to reason that I should be able
to say this I should be able to divide
this guy by that and if I divide both
sides by X plus 2 I just get left an X
plus 3 on the right hand side are you
comfortable with that idea but all I've
done is divide both sides I might even
write that 2 by both sides by Y by X
plus 2 okay now
that's just moving the algebra around
okay but what if I asked you just like I
asked here I said well if I just do
seven into 300 one 300 pounds can seven
goats go into it if I ask you this how
would you do this how would you say oh
how many X plus twos fit into x squared
plus 5x plus 6 half how do you work it
out out now that's weird because there's
numbers in there that you don't know
what their value is there are X's okay
but there is my side with long division
for numbers is because you can do long
division with polynomials and I want to
show you how so this is called
polynomial long division under under
this the first thing we do under long
division is we do a long division symbol
right so let's draw a long division
symbol wrong color here's my long
division symbol
now what this is good where well if I
have seven here in 301 here 301 is the
big number that had it sits on my memory
that's what I'm dividing right now I'm
not dividing 301 undermining that guy x
squared plus 5x plus 6 so that's what
goes underneath young x squared plus 5x
plus 6
okay now seven is what I write at the
front of my long division here cuz seven
is what I'm dividing by this time I'm
dividing by X plus 2 so X plus 2 your
hand in front okay now this next part is
a bit weird I'm going to try and explain
as best I can but we're still probably
sit a bit funny with you ok so let me
try and explain at this point I started
to go through and say well how many 7
spin two three no seven spin two three
well how many centers fit into thing and
so on okay when you have a look at this
we're not dealing with numbers anymore
or we are dealing with numbers and we
turn on what they are that's a bit
confusing okay so here's what I'm going
to do remembering that X Kim
any number I like right X could be 1 X
could be a quarter
it could be a million right it can vary
that's why we call it variable okay
X is the important number do you see
that this too is just gonna do is theme
whatever whatever happens right but if X
is like a million for example I was
wondering as I said then what you do how
many 1 million and twos fit into this
clearly the million is more important
than the two does that make sense the X
is really the term that I'm interested
in okay so when I asked how many seven
spit in 230 what corresponds to that
over here is how many X's fit into x
squared how many X's fit into X square
okay now let me just do this with some
actual numbers okay for example is X and
here's x squared okay a number like say
or if X was equal to five
what's x squared 25 so how many fives
other than 25 there are five how about a
number like say 11 what's a lemon square
121 company 11s fit in to 121 11 right
in fact how many X's fit into X square
you always get X number of X into X but
in fact that's exactly what x squared
means it's X lots of X ok so therefore
over here when I say how many X's fit
into x squared the answer is that many
X's fit into x squared ok I'm not
dealing with numbers just like here on
but this process that me writing down
that X is exactly the same as we say
there are there are four 7s that you get
nothing and there are X X's that I can
get out of x squared okay okay now when
I read that for down what did I do with
it I I multiplied it back did I not okay
and I'm gonna do exactly the same thing
here I take this edge and I'm multiply
it back x times X is x squared but I'm
not just multiplying by
squared right go by ants I did say that
to is less important but it's not like
completely unimportant it's still there
okay so I'm going to do X times the plus
two as well which is plus 2x are you
happy with that
okay now again come back to the long
division
when I got my 28 down here that was
seven times four what I do in that 28
what happened to it
what do they use it for I did a
subtraction didn't I right I did 30 take
away 28 and that gave me bit too I'm
going to do exactly the same thing here
I'm gonna do that number x squared plus
5x that's kind of like the 30 at the
front of you and I'm going to take away
x squared plus 2x when you do this
take away this how many x squared terms
get left hold on
how many x squared terms get left zero
so that just disappears but then you 5x
take away 2 X which is like you just
called me 3x UK with that okay now at
this point here up I said oh I've got a
2 left over right
excuse me then I said well I need to
bring this guy down this next number I
need to bring him into the division cuz
I haven't dealt with you yet in the same
way I've got this number hanging over
here which I hadn't brought into the
division yet so I'm going to bring him
down here plus 6 if you see that just
like I brought down the 1 here I'm gonna
bring down the next number over plus 6
yes
ah okay so the short answer is I can but
remember how I said the two is less
important but still important okay
when I consider the eggs I'm really
consuming the X plus two together which
is why I multiply the whole thing so
here I'm also going to need the two it's
also going to come into play right as
you'll see in a second how many X's fit
into 3x it's up three
so I say plus three that's um that's a
bit of a relief isn't it okay what do I
do with this three we'll just like
before I multiply it down right which
gives me 3x plus 6 what do i do at this
stage what I do last time I subtracted
and I got zero what does that zero mean
it's the remainder there's no remainder
because it divides nice and cleanly
through okay so I'm I - all right okay
so this is me saying okay well this
times this equals that and I proved it I
show that the division works with long
division what about the doing that when
I knew all that in the first place okay
and the answer is well you know a lot of
times you're going to need to find
something and the reasons that we come
clear as we get further into tunics you
way they don't divide cleanly through
okay these are the ones that exactly
work but there are others that don't so
I'm really going to quickly show you
again let's make a conclusion from this
therefore x squared plus 5x plus 6 is
equal to X plus 2 times X plus 3 plus
there's that remainder 0 hanging on the
end there